[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 loisirs chaque jeudi
l'essentiel des informations pour passer
un bon week-end dans les yvelines et
tout de suite le sommaire de cette
semaine lego playmobil mécano à
croissy-sur-seine les années 70 sont
investi le château chan auriez une
exposition rassemble jouets et jeux de
plateau pour vivre un moment de
nostalgie
profitez aussi de votre week-end pour
flâner dans les forêts et jardins
d'illinois au château de versailles
alain baraton vous emmène à la
découverte d'un arbre admirable
l'association des naturalistes des
yvelines vous initie à la cueillette des
champignons et l'agenda complet de vos
sorties au programme du cinéma du sport
et une exposition pour notre premier
rendez-vous direction croissy-sur-seine
et c'est un bond dans le temps qui vous
est proposé un voyage dans les années 70
pas de jeans pattes d'eph ou de couleurs
psychédéliques
la commune a choisi de présenter
l'époque à travers des jouets une
exposition à découvrir jusqu'au 2
février mathilde 2010 pour les images
donc là moi j'ai mon bateau voilà je dis
que c'est mon bateau parce que c'est
vrai que c'est ces bateaux que j'ai eu
moi dans les années soixante dix huit
exactement à noël on pourrait dire des
lakers qu'il est un grand enfant ce
passionné collection des jouets de son
enfance de sa passion naissent des
expositions comme les en 70 ça s'adresse
à tout le monde
donc autant plus petit qu plus qu est
née et que
aux gens qui ont vécu cette période là
en tant qu'enfant pour montrer à leurs
enfants avec elle jouait il pouvait
jouer à l'époque des années 70
immanquablement vous êtes un petit peu
pris aux tripes parce que c'est les
jouets de votre enfance en tout cas pour
ce qui me concerne moi c'étaient les
petits soldats hier fixes qui sont au
premier étage
ainsi vous avez la lune qui au dessus de
nous donc tout un tas de choses qui vous
rappelle des bons souvenirs
un voyage dans le temps et dans l'espace
à l'aube des années 70 un événement a
marqué la planète
le premier pas de l'homme sur la lune
une inspiration pour créer l'exposition
on s'est dit mais que faisait des
enfants l'époque à quoi il joue et on a
voulu faire un focus à la fois en
briques lego sur cet événement majeur
des années 70 sur l'homme qui a marché
sur la lune mais aussi sur les jouets
qui pourraient accompagner ses enfants à
l'époque à travers leurs loisirs et
leurs plaisirs il ne reste plus qu'à
enfiler vos tenues de spationaute et
laissez vous voyagez
[Musique]
dieu
soit
ouais
[Musique]
laissez vous conter les arbres château
ils sont au nombre de 350 milles il orne
les quelques 800 hectares du jardin du
château de versailles et pour leur
rendre hommage
un parcours a été créée par les
jardiniers excusez moi j'étais en train
d'écouter alain baraton le jardinier en
chef du domaine de trianon 30 armes ont
été recensées par les équipes du château
dans un circuit d'arbres admirable
allons les découvrir
[Musique]
sinon à part en bon jour mais l'ami vous
êtes le gestionnaire du patrimoine
arboré du domaine déjà pourquoi avoir
choisi de mettre en avant ces arbres on
a voulu mettre en avant les arbres
admirable du château de versailles
parce que pour nous c'est pas nous
jardinier c'est un patrimoine très
important parfois un peu méconnue alors
par exemple celui ci qui est derrière
nous ce très vieux chêne qui est le plus
vieux vieilles arbres du domaine il a
trois cent soixante-cinq ans a survécu à
la tempête de 99 et à bien d'autres il
assuré que sécheresse il a survécu à la
révolution et c'est pour ça qu'on
voulait absolument qu'il fasse partie de
notre de notre parcours
il est très certainement arriver là tout
seul mais il est fort à parier que louis
xiv et andré le nôtre sont passés sous
les frondaisons assez régulièrement on a
vu un on fait un petit on va aller en
voir d'autres on a encore quelques
autres du côté du petit trianon par
exemple
trente cas ont été identifiés par les
équipes du château en fonction de leur
âge ou de leur rapport à l'histoire
les jardiniers se sont inspirés du label
arbre remarquable face à cette année 37
sophora du japon c'est bien ça tout à
fait c'est un sophora du japon l'a
presque 200 ans et il est contemporain
de marie antoinette en fait celui là on
est sûr que c'est elle même la jeune
reine qui a demandé à ce qu'on plante un
arbre ici à cet endroit là pour qu'elle
puisse le voir depuis les fenêtres du
petit trianon et elle voulait également
un arbre asiatique un arbre exotique et
on est certain que marie-antoinette
passer le voir très souvent aimé
beaucoup cet arbre est donc c'est pour
ça qu'il est venu s'intégrer dans la
collection des arbres admirable merci
sylvain parole heures des arbres il y en
a partout et je vous propose maintenant
qu'on aille à l'orangerie
[Musique]
à l'orangerie cinq spécimens ont été
identifiés alors voilà un grenadier qui
est moi je les aime beaucoup parce que
j'aime l'aspect torturé comme ça du
tronc ce côté un peu baroque associé à
la régularité
là on est vraiment dans le jardin on va
dire régulier c'est ce jardin maîtrisé
par cette nature maîtrisée par l'homme
pour profiter de ces arbres admirable il
vous faut pas grand-chose il vous faut
votre téléphone
des écouteurs télécharger l'application
qui ne vous reste plus qu'à en profiter
moi il me reste encore une vingtaine je
vais y aller en ce week-end prolongé
vous serez peut-être tenter de vous
rendre en forêt pour faire la cueillette
des champignons
une balade à faire en famille mais
pendant laquelle il faut être attentif
tous les champignons ne sont donc pas
comestible à chaque année de nombreux
cas d'intoxication sont recensés et
marylène yapi chine on a été chercher
quelques précieux conseils auprès des
tiennes varney il est membre de
l'association des naturalistes des
yvelines
la première question en général c'est
savoir si c'est bon ou pas bon mais ce
qui est important avant avant cela bien
sûr c'est de reconnaître les champignons
comme si champignons on est saisi il
faut être toujours très prudent de ne
manger que les quelques champignons
qu'on connaît bien avec un couteau bien
ramasser la base du champignon pouvoir
lance en deux
la base du pied qui est importante pas
couper le champignon au milieu ce qui
rendra l'identification difficile
mortels et pour ceux qui souhaiteraient
se rassurent et l'ani propose trois
sorties en ce long week-end de toussaint
en forêt de bennes de fausses reposes ou
encore de bois d'arcy et pour plus
d'information direction du site internet
de l'association qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran
comme chaque semaine on retrouve notre
instant cinéma de nouveaux films sont à
voir dans les salles obscures et en
cette période d'halloween pourquoi ne
pas vous laisser tenter avec retour à
zombieland avec woody harrelson jesse
eisenberg emma stone ou encore abigail
breslin nicolas landry et patrick
jacques de dixmude ont recueilli les
avis des premiers spectateurs
[Musique]
c'est l'heure de se la péter ou de la
boucler
très bon film en tout cas dans la
continuité du premier donc beaucoup
d'humour et vraiment je suis ravi c'est
drôle j'ai déjà vu le premier alors dix
ans se sont écoulés depuis l'apocalypse
zombie cette famille dysfonctionnelle
joie tu veux savoir ce que j'aimerais je
m'en contrefous double des vrais a
survécu en faisant preuve de
discernement
doué pour la survie
alors envie parce que les zombies se
nourrissent de cervelle et qu'elle a
rien dans le crâne
les personnages se libère sympa c'est
pas trop gore pour les enfants et ben
non c'est les dialogues qui sont rigolos
les situations c'était marrant mais ça
fait pas non plus trop peur est bas les
personnages ils sont attachants ouais
vieux monsieur est tout petit il n'est
plus là il est le plus de voix cela ça
ne fait pas peur non non c'est bon et un
peu de gore comme parce que c'est un
film de zombies mais c'est très très
très drôle à la fois on pense que c'est
sérieux mais non ce n'est pas du tout
sérieux c'est vraiment de la déconne
jusqu'à la fin
c
aujourd'hui
quand même
[Musique]
un peu de sport à présent ce week-end
c'est aussi la course royal plus de 500
participants seront sur la ligne de
départ à la pièce d'eau des suisses de
versailles 10 et 20 km les attentes pour
rejoindre fontenay le fleury 1 euro par
participant sera reversée au téléthon
organisé par la ville de fontenay le 7
décembre prochain
et pourquoi ne pas vous glisser parmi
les 600 spectateurs attendus le long du
parcours quelques précisions et on
traverse la plaine de versailles le parc
du château de versailles pour arriver
dans la commune de fontaines fleuries
l'ia de petites complications mais c'est
beaucoup plus de plat et avec eux ce qu
on dit dans le jargon découvrir un petit
casse pattes comment la fin de course
pour leur faire voir que voilà ces
données c'est pas non plus une partie de
plaisir
un mot de rugby à présent avec la 5e
journée de championnat honneur l'union
rugby centre reçoit ce dimanche à 15
heures au stade du bout des clots de
maurepas le club vie au grand air de
saint maur les saint quentinois sont
favoris de la rencontre ils sont
actuellement 4e du championnat viotto
grand-air pointe à la 9e place
on parle maintenant faire un petit tour
en ile de france peut-être avez-vous
rêvé un jour de devenir un espion à la
cité des sciences vous pouvez vous
tester avec une exposition autour des
métiers du renseignement c'est un sujet
de nos confrères de via campari espion
c'est certainement le métier le plus
secret au monde et en même temps celui
qui intrigue le plus la cité des
sciences et de l'industrie a donc décidé
de lever le voile sur l'univers si
particulier de l'espionnage pour sa
nouvelle exposition
elle présente les différentes facettes
et les techniques liées aussi services
de renseignement français à travers un
parcours immersif cette exposition elle
commence par un sas et du moment vous
passez ce sas vous quitter l'espace du
musée pour rentrer au coeur des services
de renseignement donc vous n'êtes plus
un simple visiteur mais vous devenez un
agent de renseignements on vous apprend
que a été détecté un essai nucléaire de
faible intensité mais le président de la
république qu'on voit que les six
services et demande sous 48 heures une
note de renseignement et donc c'est vous
qui allez devoir collecter des
informations pour pouvoir ensuite les
analyses
les recouper et donc rédigé cette note
de renseignement donc on va faire d'eux
les coudes sonore enfers de l'étude de
vidéosurveillance on va devoir
dépoussiérer un bureau qu'on va vraiment
devoir agir et se mettre dans la peau
d'un agent
grâce à une collaboration avec la série
du bureau des légendes et à la
participation directe des services de
renseignement la cité des sciences et de
l'industrie a mis sur pied un rendez
vous ludique et surtout crédible
l'objectif est de présenter une image
réaliste du monde de l'espionnage
loin des clichés véhiculés par le cinéma
l'objectif de cette exposition en fait
c'est de montrer tous les métiers
propres aux renseignements on a des
métiers scientifiques on a des métiers
techniques on a des métiers qui relève
plutôt de compétences humaines
psychologique donc là en se mettant à la
place d'un agent on découvre tout cela
l'objectif ici est aussi de démythifier
un tout un tas de d'idées reçues
james bond n'existe pas je suis désolé
james bond à lui tout seul il incarne
plus de 70 métiers que comporte le
renseignement donc évidemment tout ça
c'est pas possible ce serait un surhomme
donc là vous allez découvrir
véritablement les compétences et les
différents métiers et c'est déjà assez
extraordinaire venez découvrir espion à
la cité des sciences et de l'industrie
jusqu'au 9 ou 2020 c'est la fin de ce
cette ut loisirs merci de nous avoir
suivis vous pouvez revoir cette émission
en replay sur notre site internet et
applications mobiles
on se retrouve jeudi prochain à 18h30
pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]
ouais
et
oh